Today, we are going to learn
about why comedy is funny,
and how to use humor to make
yourself rich and famous.
(Brandon pops into existence)
- Whoa!
Are you Poppy?
- Welcome to my show
- I love you.
I'm going to be able to
write a hilarious bit
because of this
random situation.
- Bits are my favorite
part about comedy,
because they're a perfect
way to tell jokes.
What's your best bit?
- Oh, my best bit?
I have one about going to
a Justin Bieber concert,
and he makes everyone
pray with him.
- Justin Bieber is a celebrity,
and if you talk
about celebrities,
more people will
think you're funny.
- Wow, I never really thought
about it like that, Poppy.
I'm gonna tell more jokes
about famous celebrities,
and then I, too, will
be a famous celebrity.
- The truth is, most
people have nothing to say.
And because of that, most
people are unbelievably boring.
- Poppy, I love your videos,
because they make
my brain feel funny.
- I love you, Brandon.
- I love you, too, Poppy.
I love doing posts
and going viral.
- I love all of you.